je vis attention décembre 99 avec un
téléphone portable et une escouade de
mutins le général gaye arracher le
pouvoir aux héritiers corrompu de
l'ancien président houphouët boigny
libère des opposants et s'engage à
rendre le pouvoir une fois passé je cite
un ballet mais dix mois plus tard en
troquant le treillis pour le costume de
candidat à la présidence celui que les
ivoiriens avaient surnommé le général
père noël s'est transformé en père
fouettard
il sait invalider la candidature de ses
rivaux politiques
à une exception près et sa milice
liquide dans l'ombre plusieurs de ses
anciens frères d'armes
en septembre il échappera de justesse à
la vindicte d'une arme est qu'il ne
contrôle plus depuis longtemps en
essayant hier de convaincre manu
militari le président de la commission
électorale de le déclarer président élu
le général gaye joue le coup de force et
perd ses derniers soutiens
internationaux en février celui qui
voulait faire marcher la démocratie
ivoirienne au pas cadencé avait aussi
tenté de mettre au pas les joueurs de la
sélection nationale ivoirienne
éliminé en coupe d'afrique il ya
quelques jours le général gueï disait
sans rire sont désunis nous courons à
l'échec
unis nous y parviendrons c'est bien
involontairement la seule promesse qu'il
est vraiment tenu